ouf le satellite nucléaires soviétiques
ne retombera pas sur la terre il s'est
désintégré dans l'atmosphère à moscou
gorbatchev prend tous les pouvoirs
secrétaire général du parti il devient
chef de l'état en 48 heures il a éliminé
huit adversaires de sa politique
cinq millions de français ont vu le film
le grand bleu le héros existe il
s'appelle jacques mayol et nous l'avons
rencontré un document exceptionnel à la
fin de ce journal
madame monsieur bonsoir la clôture des
jeux de séoul aura lieu cette nuit vous
pourrez la suivre en direct sur antenne
2 avec la dernière compétition symbole
de l'olympisme s'il en est le marathon
étant donné que la france n'espère pas
figurer malheureusement bonne place dans
cette épreuve
on peut dès ce soir faire les cons
quinze médailles dont cinq d'or pour la
france ce qui place notre délégation 11e
rang des 30 pays qui ont reçu au moins
une médaille
l'urss terminant en tête avec 127
médailles devant l'allemagne de l'est
sans une et les états unis
89 les deux dernières médailles
françaises bronze au 4 x 100 m et argent
en boxe c'est celle ci que nous
retiendrons cas pour son détenteur
laurent boudouani elle brille comme de
l'or une véritable consécration pour ce
fils d'une famille de harkis installés
dans la région de sallanches en
haute-savoie les harkis ces soldats
d'origine algérienne qui se sont battus
pour la france en algérie qui n'ont pas
forcément reçu dans notre pays l'accueil
qu'ils étaient en droit d'espérer taux
de régent la droite meurtrière du kenyan
langil à armin et toutes les espérances
de laurent boudouani pour une médaille
d'or
e
les enfants rient comptoir seigneurie
fois
à sallanches cet après midi dans le
petit quartier ouvrier
tout le monde a partagé la joie de la
famille boudouani les amis alors il
apparut demande le magnétophone passent
et repassent les combats de laurent le
père qui doivent y est encore très ému
il est plus que fière de l'eau rendent
le plus grand pourvoyeur de coupe et de
récompense d'une famille où les quatre
garçons son boxeur ben on est très
content le cher pour une fois qu'est-ce
qu'ils emportent la déception du dernier
match où la joie de la médaille c'est
une petite ville tout le monde se
connaît
on notait déjà tous derrière lui avant
qu'il parte ben il a été aidé à mener le
maté d'argent était en sommes très fiers
de lui et c'est les copains ne sont pas
en reste une médaille d'argent a fait de
laurent le grand frère parti quelqu'un
de bien oui tout le monde parle de lui
c'est un bon boxeur des fois je fais de
karaté moi le moment ça je regarde ça et
il m'impressionne où ça fait de son
entraînement tous un super pote faire
honneur pratiquement les quinze ans elle
sait le faire deux instruments 10 heures
est vraiment content pour lui à
sallanches on prépare la fête une fête
simple et vrai mardi soir dès le retour
de séoul de laurent le médaillé une
menace de moins au dessus de nos têtes
ouf les soviétiques ont fait savoir
officiellement en fin d'après midi
qu'ils avaient réussi à expédier dans
l'espace le réacteur nucléaire de leurs
satellites cosmos 1900 en perdition et
celui ci le satellite se serait lui-même
désintégrer dans l'atmosphère
tout danger est donc apparemment écarté
et ce satellite ne devrait plus nous
provoquer de belles frayeurs comme hier
soir sur l'autoroute du nord jacques
violet
fanny psychose cette grosse boule
couvertes de petits miroirs
réfléchissants et qui dégageait de la
fumée a fait penser hier en fin de
soirée que cosmos 1900 venait de tomber
sur terre peu avant 21h un garagiste qui
l'aperçoit sur le bas côté de
l'autoroute du nord dans la somme donne
l'alertent on parle de radioactivité
personne n'ose approcher la circulation
est coupée
on attend les équipes de secours une
heure plus tard tout le monde est
rassuré l'ovni n'est qu'un décor de fête
foraine tombée d'un camion
une soirée qui aura prouvé que les
services de sécurité étaient bien près
au niveau de tous les services y eu
aucun problème
ça fait une bonne valeur ce matin
cosmo se rapprochait toujours de notre
terre les spécialistes du monde entier
suivait sa trajectoire en début d'après
midi une cellule d'information ont été
mises en place à paris mais à 16 heures
les techniciens soviétiques annonçait
que le système automatique à bord du
satellite avait expulsé le réacteur
nucléaire à très haute altitude dans
l'espace où il restera deux très longues
années le reste du satellite s'est
désintégrée en rentrant dans
l'atmosphère au-dessus du groenland mais
sachez quand même qu'il y à aude sus de
nos têtes quelques 7000 objets divers
satellites en état de marche mais aussi
débris de fusées de toute sorte et qu'il
tend ou sur terre environ 6 tonnes de
météorites naturelle ou artificielle par
jour mais sans réel danger après la
technique soviétique la politique à
moscou mikhaïl gorbatchev prend
aujourd'hui le pouvoir pour la deuxième
fois secrétaire général du parti
communiste véritable numéro 1 d'ailleurs
depuis 1985
et bien comme ses prédécesseurs il s'est
fait introniser ce matin chef de l'état
pas le soviet suprême le parlement
soviétique et par la même occasion il
s'est débarrassé de ses derniers
adversaires qui comptait huit au total
dans monsieur gromyko et le patron du
puissant kgb les services secrets
corinne pertuis temps
de plus en plus vite de plus en plus
fort convoquée à la hâte jeudi dernier
les députés du parlement soviétique ont
à peine eu le temps de réaliser ce qui
se passait dès l'ouverture de la session
ce matin ils ont entériné les décisions
prises en une heure de temps hier par le
plénum du comité central limogeage est
mise à la retraite en série d'un geste
il met fin à la longue carrière d'andreï
gromyko à cet instant aussi impassible
qu'à l'habitude
101 tremblements dans la voix celui qui
dirigea pendant un quart de siècle la
diplomatie soviétique a à peine le temps
de rendre hommage à la pérestroïka l'est
déjà
l'éveil kof le chef du parti de moscou
monte à la tribune et propose la
candidature de mikhaïl gorbatchev au
poste laissé vacant
quelques instants plus tôt par andrei
gromyko surprise dans l'auditoire on
s'attendait à un tel vote au mois de
mars prochain
mais la discipline de parti et de mise
sous les applaudissements mikhaïl
gorbatchev est élu chef de l'état
à l'unanimité ils fument hull désormais
cette fonction avec celle de secrétaire
général du parti
mais quelques combats de chauffe qui a
manifestement voulu prendre de vitesse
ses adversaires a parfaitement réussi
son coup la séance aura duré 45 minutes
leurs premiers commentaires sur ces
changements intervenus à moscou georges
bortoli si michael gorbatchev de tous
les pouvoirs
c'est évidemment pour être le seul
maître incontesté du kremlin mais aussi
dans l'avenir pour rééquilibrer la
direction du pays entre le parti
communiste et les organes du
gouvernement officiel tout à fait parce
que comme vous le dites
le système soviétique c'est un système à
double commande n'est ce pas il ya d'une
part un gouvernement qui ne gouverne pas
faut être honnête parce que derrière le
gouvernement il ya les hauts
fonctionnaires du parti communiste qui
eux ont les vrais pouvoirs
bon alors dans le projet de réforme des
institutions qui l'a annoncé et qu'il a
réaffirmé ce matin au sujet de suprême
monsieur gorbatchev a l'intention de
rendre le parti un petit peu moins
interventionniste et les organes
du gouvernement et les organes de l'état
si vous voulez un peu plus autonome et
je veux dire il va être bien placé pour
arbitrer entre sam et à droite et sa
gauche en quelque sorte puisque massa
est à la fois l'état et le parti bon
alors si les entames des teintes un peu
plus pouvoir ça veut dire qu'on peut
donner aussi un peu plus d'autonomie aux
responsables économiques qui jusqu'à
présent ont été complètement tenus en
lisière par les responsables politiques
par les choix politiques et c'est ça au
fond qui intéresse le soviétique moyens
parce que bon monsieur grand badge of
change des têtes au politburo wire mais
ce qui intéresse vraiment l'homme de la
rue c'est que le ravitaillement
s'améliore merci georges à l'étranger
encore déstabilisé depuis la mort du
général zia cet été le pakistan connaît
aujourd'hui des affrontements entre
différentes ethnies qui composent le
pays un premier bilan fait état
d'environ 200 morts et presque autant de
blessés thierry km les rues de karachi
au petit matin après une nuit d'émeutes
et de massacres près de 200 morts selon
un quotidien de la capitale pakistanaise
tout a commencé hyderabad dans le sud du
pays deux groupes ethniques rivaux se
sont affrontés tirant dans la foule
incendiant et pillant des magasins
vingt personnes abattues à la sortie
d'un cinéma vendredi soir et en même
temps des voitures circulaient dans les
quartiers de la périphérie avec à leur
bord des tireurs qui arrosaient la foule
alarmes automatiques les hôpitaux
refuser les blessés à cause du manque de
sang pour les transfusions
ce matin le gouvernement a décrété le
couvre-feu dans les deux villes mais les
autorités restent muettes sur le bilan
et les causes exactes de ces émeutes
à quatre jours du plébiscite qu'il a
lui-même organisé au chili le général
pinochet est toujours en butte aux
manifestations de l'opposition et
pourtant vers le chef de l'état emploie
tous les moyens vraiment tous les moyens
à sa disposition pour l'emporter il
s'est même livré hier à une autocritique
télévisée ce qui n'est pas vous le savez
dans ses habitudes valérie fournier
depuis la dette officielle de sa
candidature au plébiscite le général
pinochet a tout fait pour changer son
image de dictateur en démocrate
hier lors d'une allocution télévisée il
imploré les chiens
lien si j'ai fait quelque chose de mal
pardonnez-moi le général pinochet semble
avoir peur peur du retour en force de
l'opposition
cet après-midi une marche pour la joie
organisées par les partisans du non a eu
lieu à santiago plusieurs milliers de
chiliens ont tenu à dire qu'ils
n'oublieront jamais les actes du général
pinochet perpétrés en quinze ans de
pouvoir
la campagne électorale se termine
officiellement demain et à l'heure du
bilan
l'opposition se déclarent satisfaites
les derniers sondages en date sont
contradictoires il faudra attendre le
décompte des bulletins de vote du 5
octobre prochain pour savoir si le
général pinochet doit prendre sa
retraite ou s'il obtient une
prolongation de son mandat jusqu'en 1997
auquel cas cela porterait à 25 ans la
durée de son exercice au pouvoir en
france la traditionnelle fête du
syndicat force ouvrière à paris sur la
pelouse de reuilly est teinté cette
année de nostalgie même de chagrin pour
cette certains en effet son secrétaire
confédéral depuis 25 ans maintenant un
quart de siècle andré bergeron fait ses
adieux officiels il doit prendre sa
retraite à la fin de cette année à près
de mon maire à la cdt c'est le deuxième
grand personnage du syndicalisme des
années 60 qui disparaît un site de la
scène publique
maryse mano didier d'art
c'est sûr qu'on pousse et qu'est ce
qu'il représente
j'ai une longue lutte ensemble une larme
d'émotion l'oeuvre en guise d'adieu au
patro pour ceux qui ont connu le front
populaire le départ de dédé andré
bergeron est un crève coeur
c'est cette fête de force ouvrière un
petit air de nostalgie
15en à pied que je ne loupe jamais une
fête de l'amitié
mais je ne loupe jamais les discours
d'andré vert blanc jamais je suis
toujours là je suis un fidèle
évidemment il va me manquer énormément
parce que dd pour nous cette sphère
mais il ya ce qui attend son départ sans
crainte car la succession est déjà
ouvert deux candidats font leur campagne
au milieu des stands les scrutins sera
serré le plus voyant marc blondel est un
ancien de la sf fille au truculent ce
fils de mineur serait sans doute plus
progressistes qu andré bergeron plus à
gauche c'est certain que le strip
problème
les bretelles à l'opposé claude pitou
c'est discret toujours dans l'ombre
d'andré bergeron lors et la préférence
du patro il représente la continuité
jusqu'ici le secrétaire général n'a
donné aucun coup de pouce à l'un ou
l'autre candidat
il aurait pu le faire aujourd'hui il
savait bien gardé l'important à force
ouvrière et de ne pas rompre l'
équilibre entre les différents courants
il y aura quelqu'un d'élus pour me
remplacer chez le comité confédéral
national qui le décidera mais je
souhaite que quel qu'il soit on se
rassemble autour de lui un adieu en
forme de supplique pour conjurer les
risques de déchirements dans ce syndicat
ou le fondateur en effet le ciment
sur un plan strictement syndicale celui
la force ouvrière appelle pour les 6 et
7 octobre prochains l'ensemble des
agents hospitaliers à la grève car ils
considèrent que les problèmes de
salaires ne concerne pas uniquement les
infirmières statu quo dans le mouvement
de protestation des gardiens de prison
ils poursuivent leur grève du zèle
empêchant notamment les visites et la
cgt appelle jeudi prochain à une
manifestation à paris épilogue
provisoire de la sphère de
l'augmentation du tarif des cartes
bancaires après le crédit lyonnais de la
bnp a décidé de renoncer
seul désormais donc la société générale
maintient ses positions
demain deuxième tour des élections
cantonales ce deuxième tour
provoquera-t-il un regain d'intérêt de
la part des électeurs qui s'étaient
abstenus à 50% la semaine dernière on
peut l'espérer sinon on ne pourra guère
tirer les enseignements de ce scrutin
roland site à 11 166 sièges de
conseillers généraux à pourvoir le
second tour des élections cantonales va
permettre d'établir le rapport de force
entre les différents partis qui animent
la vie politique
globalement l'equilibre ne devrait pas
être bouleversé deux départements
risquent de basculer de la gauche vers
la droite le tarn et les alpes de haute
provence
inversement la gironde l'allier l'isère
et l'indre pourrait revenir à la gauche
en fait tout dépendra des reports de
voix première incertitude l'attitude des
électeurs du front national jean marie
le pen appelé ses partisans à s'abstenir
sauf dans les cantons où les candidats
rpr et udf avait expressément demandé
son soutien
les résultats de dimanche permettront de
mesurer l'emprise de l'extrême droite
sur son électorat second d'incertitude
les reports à gauche
presque partout les désistements se sont
fait sans problème le scrutin montrera
si les électeurs suivent les consignes
de leurs états majors une série de tests
qui risque pourtant de perdre une grande
partie de sa signification à cause d'une
dernière inconnue
l'abstention dimanche dernier plus de la
moitié des électeurs n'étaient pas allés
voter
le journal le monde fait état dans son
édition d'aujourd'hui d'un rapport de
police confidentiels demandée par le
juge d'instruction grelier dans la
r de corruption dans laquelle michel
droit membre de la commission nationale
de la communication et des libertés est
toujours inculpé pour se défendre
l'académicien aurait produit une série
de faux à propos de ses rapports
financiers avec le groupe de presse de
robert hersant une information bien sûr
qui est toujours à prendre au
conditionnel forcément spectaculaire
l'actualité oui vite ensuite ses
victimes en juin dernier souvenez-vous
lors d'une démonstration à mulhouse à un
airbus a320 s'écrasait au sol faisant
trois morts et plusieurs blessés
trois mois après trois mois plus tard
des familles de victimes attendent
toujours des explications et des blessés
les plus graves
leur indemnisation delphine de la scène
pierre izard
une catastrophe ce n'est pas uniquement
des images brutales choquant dans un
journal télévisé une catastrophe c'est
la vie qui continue brisé c'est un
cauchemar qui revient permanent c'est
l'histoire d'un enfant déjà marquée par
le sort
hervé lerman il avait 14 ans il était
paralysée sanglé dans sa coquille
il ne pourra s'extraire de l'avion qui
brûlent malgré les efforts de son jeune
ami il n'a peut être pas crier assez
fort le personnel de bord l'a oublié son
père en état de choc n'a pas voulu nous
rencontrer un autre enfant est mort
mariana barry son billet elle l'avait
gagnée dans une loterie
incapable de s'en sortir seul elle a
crié au secours une femme l'a entendu
elle s'appelait marie françoise frêche
d'après les pompiers parlent ensuite
nous à retrouver le club de corps
d'armée femme et la petite fille qu'ils
étaient pratiquement dans ces cas-là du
moment de le sortir
la petite fille est de se reprendre
connaissance a dû crier ou appeler au
secours
l'assurance a contacté un home auquel
cas je raterais donc en nous demandant
de jeunes est en rapport avec eux pour
nous pour constituer un dossier et moi
j'aurais répondu qu' actuellement et moi
je ne vais pas traumatiser qu' on n'est
pas en mesure de discuter trois morts
est ce qu'on appelle les miraculés
stéphane par exemple un adepte du vol à
voile
aujourd'hui il souffre de fractures d'un
tassement de vertèbres son état ne lui
permet pas de poursuivre ses études
depuis l'accident j'ai les incapacités
physiques j'ai pas le droit de m'asseoir
et - cause de ça j'ai dû interrompre mes
études et puis il bon je pense souvent à
l'accident ou de retourner à l'hôpital
ça se passe comment bah oui
régulièrement je dois aller refaire des
radios et pour savoir la suite à donner
aussi à mes blessures et j'attends
prochaine manche de membres de nouvelles
people pour savoir ce qu'ils comment ça
va continuer si je peux m'asseoir ou
bien derrière la souffrance physique
morale
la machine judiciaire les familles se
sont portées parties civiles
rené meyer le père de stéphane a
constitué une association de défense
pour les victimes
son objectif les indemnisations rapide
et conséquente sommes absolument un fou
nous n'avons absolument rien perçu et
nous ne savons pas le montant de
l'indemnité que nous percevons une idée
jusqu'à présent aucune provision n'a été
versées par les assurances chaque
situation est très particulière et donc
on peut pas y a pas de de délai le délai
c'est dès qu'on peut apprécier
l'importance du préjudice
le procès risque de durer longtemps
plusieurs années peut-être les dossiers
seront examinés un par un les avocats
des victimes vont plaider la faute
inexcusable
on parle ici d'argent car pour la
justice tout a un prix
les dégâts matériels comme la douleur
aux sports maintenant les femmes
conquiert définitivement un nouveau
domaine celui de la moto puisque au bol
d'or du castellet un équipage
entièrement féminin a pris le départ cet
après-midi sur la ligne de départ
justement 72 hommes et trois femmes
thierry blanc
deux américaines et une française égale
l'unique équipage féminin de la plus
grande course d'endurance moto du monde
véronique parisot 31 ans toni sharpless
et kathleen coburn deux canadiennes
particularité toutes les trois sont
dingues le sport mécanique sur deux ou
quatre roues
décontracté dans l'ensemble les filles
autographes et punk cuisine mais
attention sérieuse comme les sommes en
compétition avec un objectif bien précis
pour leur première participation au bol
c'est pas nécessaire d'aller très très
vite par contre si on peut arriver à
rouler relativement régulièrement sont
la machine et le moins de problème on
peut espérer au moins finir dans les dix
premiers
excitation surexcitation et regard des
premiers ratés
départ plus que moyen en queue de
peloton de quoi vous décourager la plus
mordus des femmes pilotes
et pourtant depuis 15 heures elles n'ont
fait que remonter au classement
alors admiration messieurs
trop tard quand même la bible et dans la
ligne droite et que dans les virages
mais bon tout ça très sympathique je
pense qu'elles ont leur mot à dire parce
qu'elle roule très bien les trouver ces
faits charmante
ben voyons à suivre la yamaha numéro 12
24 heures c'est long
catherine véronique et audi sont ce soir
32e au classement à neuf tours des motos
de tête c'est déjà une belle performance
et sans doute mais oui c'est un beau
souvenir
devinez qui partira en tête demain du
grand prix d'espagne de formule 1
automobile pas très difficile c'est le
brésilien ayrton senna devant le
français alain prost tous les deux
frères ennemis sur mclaren honda
mais qui est donc ce champion brésilien
exceptionnel un pilote hors pair sûr
mais aussi un homme tranquille
lionel chamoulaud
senna pole position la 11e de la saison
le brésilien malgré ce tête-à-queue et
le plus rapide sur un tour
senna l'espoir du brésil c'est l'enfant
chéri ces valeurs sont celles qui
touchent tout un peuple comme la famille
ici avec son frère fernando j'ai
vraiment une super famille j'aime la vie
j'ai une existence qui me convient je
n'ai pas de regret et pas de quoi me
plaindre je crois que je suis tout
simplement un homme heureux heureux
surtout lorsqu'il va vite sur la piste
à 28 ans magic senna n'a qu'un but
devenir champion du monde
cette victoire cette saison mais procès
toujours menaçant alors ayrton pas
encore plus de risques et il travaille
encore plus dur c'est un maniaque un
obsédé du détail de la perfection il
s'inspire de proches mais veut aller
plus loin
il n'est qu'à une victoire d'un titre
qui devrait chambouler son existence
c'est vrai que si j'étais champion cela
devrait être différent mais je suis ce
que je suis ma vie ne tient pas un
succès je fais ce que j'aime
il n'y a pas de raison que cela change
j'ai reçu des principes fondamentaux
d'éducation et je continuerai à les
suivre
il n'y a pas de raison de changer l'oeil
inquiet de prost le français doit gagner
deux maps pour conserver ses chances
l'explication à estoril a été sévère
entre les deux hommes dimanche elle
risque d'être tout aussi musclé
le voici maintenant ce document promis
dans les titres sur le grand bleu un
film de luc besson que plus de cinq
millions d'entre vous ont vu à ce jour
ce film vous ne le savez peut-être pas
est tiré d'une histoire vraie le héros
jacques mayol plongeur en apnée c'est à
dire sans appareil est un ami de notre
reporter roger morineau le vrai grand
bleu existe donc et comme cela arrive
parfois
et bien la réalité est plus fort que la
fiction
regardez le vrai jacques mayol en
plongée près d'haïti
un marseillais né à shanghai un grand
père âgé de 61 ans avec une histoire qui
n'a rien à voir avec celle de
l'adolescent timide et illuminé décrit
dans le film rien à voir sauf l'amour et
les dauphins et ce don incroyable ce
qu'offre la capacité de rester sous
l'eau cinq minutes à des dizaines de
mètres de profondeur dont travailler et
développer aux indes
grâce à un yoga particulier pour langues
et dans les années 50 jacques mayol fut
bûcheron suède journaliste chercheur
d'or au canada
un jour en floride la révélation les à
157 les travailler ici comme frondeurs
et comme le dresseur de dauphins 57 et
cinq ans
je m'étais lié d'amitié disons j'ai une
petite île à faire romantique avec
dauphin femelle ou non de cloud qui
était la prima donna veilleux et je
reviens presque chaque année je reviens
retrouver mais les cousins examen pour
rejoindre les dauphins my all bat des
records qu'on préfère appeler expérience
ici au large de l'île d'elbe à 55 en
descente à moins 105 m en apnée c'est à
dire sans bouteille sans équipement le
grand bleu devient noir une gueuse dix
ans à l'est un profond dit m c'est tout
sa cage thoracique devrait exploser
moins 105 mètres officiel autour de lui
les plongeurs témoins harnachés mayol
lui remonte tranquillement sans
s'arrêter
son coeur ne bat cave un coût par minute
le sang se concentrent dans le cerveau
et la région cardiaque un circuit court
comme les mammifères marins
voilà ce qui physiologiquement lui
procure une paix une extase
difficilement exprimable une communion
c'est comme un dauphin
je m'imaginais j'étais voici enzo le
rival dans la vie comme dans le fim enzo
maiorca de son vrai nom italien de
syracuse 57 ans grand père lui aussi et
bon vivant
en juillet dernier il descendait en
apnée à moins 101 m qui est le meilleur
enzo et jacques chicane à propos de
quelques mètres ne pas penser se laisser
transporter avec les dauphins
c'est le secret de mayol en australie il
enseigne aux petits enfants ont replongé
dans l'eau le liquide originel comment
vas-tu ce matin aux questions de mélo
qui dira sa fiancée angela une danseuse
aquatique à profiter des leçons des
leçons d'amour de la vie et des dauphins
tel speedy ça fait six ans je connais ce
débat c'était absolument remarquable de
tous les d'après je connais vraiment à
la 30 ans pour moi
c'est le plus intelligent le plus
copains coquins le plus le plus vif 50
ans est morte s'il ya un mois et depuis
souffre de crises de l'effet des crises
de dépression terrible
d'ailleurs nous venons souvent pour lui
de tenir un peu compagnie fait entendre
un peu de musique sur le calme mais
notre projet c'est vraiment de le
libérer de la mener avec nous à l'île
d'elbe en liberté totale il aura le
choix soit de partir soit de rester
parmi
revenir de temps en temps speedy jacques
mayol hommes dauphin mystère sa vue le
ce document commenté par thierry
calmette est extraite d'un film réalisé
par roger morineau et qui sera présentée
je vous le signale au festival mondial
de l'image sous-marine du 12 au 16
octobre prochain à antibes si vous avez
l'occasion de vous y rendre
ne manquez pas surtout cette chance le
tiercé maintenant il y en avait 1 cet
après midi qui se courait il ya même eu
trois gagnants le 12 le 14 et le 3 comme
d'habitude avec un rapport 2972 franc
pour ce qui concerne le tiercé du moins
et pour ce qui concerne le quarté vous
allez ajouter un concurrent vous allez
ajouter le neuf
non vous n'ajoutez pas le neuf si vous
ajoutez le neuf et ça rapporte un peu
plus quand même 13 1200 tr seront 80 ça
c'était cet après-midi pour ce qui
concerne demain et bien c'est l'une des
plus grandes classiques de la saison le
grand prix de l'arc de triomphe qui ne
rapportera pas pire est sans doute
beaucoup d'argent aux joueurs mais en
tout cas une belle somme au vainqueur au
propriétaire du vainqueur 5 millions de
voix exactement et puis à plus d'un
titre ce ne sera pas un tiercé comme
tous les autres ceux ci galerie d'art de
triomphe qui se courra demain après midi
à longchamp car ce championnat du monde
des pur-sang réuni toute élite les plus
grands cracks européen
les vainqueurs de toutes les grandes
courses classiques vont s'affronter dans
ce match finale qui se jouera sur 2400
mètres à distance et classique alors
parmi les 24 concurrents engagés dans ce
prix de l'arc de triomphe
il n'y a pas vraiment un favori qui se
détache côté français si diane rose la
plus belle pouliche une belle blonde qui
appartient à l'écurie rothschild sera
certainement notre meilleure chance
regardez avec quelle facilité elle
s'envole vers la victoire dans le prix
vermeille indian rose c'est la casaque
bleue top jaune
elle laisse sur place ceux d'anne love
et surtout l'oeil de light qu'elle
retrouvera demain dans l'arc
alors malheureusement indian rose et est
boiteuse en début de semaine alors est
elle tout à fait rétabli c'est là la
véritable question
le deuxième favori français nous allons
le voir gagner le prix niel il s'appelle
fischer tango et porte la casaque verte
des houches de mammouth rustock
c'est un poulain qui a toutes les
qualités plus c'est dur
ge est à son aise ici lutte avec kaya si
le cheval de l'aga qu'envers top
vertèbres et rouge qui termine 2e et qui
sera lui aussi favori de l'arc de
triomphe si gammée sur cette image que
nous allons voir maintenant regardez
bien c'est le troisième cheval
voilà le troisième cheval s'appelle
chars obs et ce cheval là qui
m'intéresse car en effet dans le
pronostic que je vous propose est
maintenant bien j'ai décidé de ne pas
placer un favori en tête de la sélection
mais plutôt un bon outsider
il s'agit de sharon qui porte le numéro
13 qui sera donc en tête de ma sélection
fut suivie de callas il ose ntoto
leucate tony been le cette triche numéro
10 diminuendo le 21 glacial ce tome le
19 et une fugue wayne le 12 merci pire
est juste avant de nous quitter je vous
donne lecture d'une dépêche qui tomba à
l'instant 20h28 la réalisation de la
jihad islamique dans un communiqué
publié à l'instant même donc à beyrouth
annonce sa décision de relâcher un des
quatre otages qu'elle détient encore en
ce moment au liban parmi ces quatre
otages il y a trois américains et un
chercheur indien la dépêche vient de
tomber à l'instant sans doute des
développements dans notre dernier
journal présenté aux alentours de 23h15
par philippe gassot en attendant tout de
suite après le générique du journal la
météo avec josé blanc lapierre quant à
moi je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée et je vous dis à demain 13h pour
soi
oh